In this presentation, I will solve additional examples about
Simplify root phrases
These include collection and subtraction
Different radical expressions
I think this tool is good
If you have not seen it before
So let's start
Suppose I have a 3 x square root for 8 - has
We previously learned that the square root of
8, or the square root positive for 8-- - 6 ×
Square root of 32
Now see what can be done to simplify the phrase
First, the 8 can be typed in 2 x 4 format
The 4 is a whole square, maybe you are
You realize that
They can be analyzed into 2 × 2 factors
But I do not think we will need this step
We can write 3 square root of 8 in this manner: 3 ×
Square root of 4 × square root of 2
This is the same as the square root of 4 × 2
Ie square root of 8
If this phrase is the same
Then take a look at 32
We want to find the square root of 32
32 is 2 × 16
Again, 16 words are a whole square, if
We can stop there
If they do not realize this, they can be analyzed
To the factors of 4 × 4
Where you see that 4 times repeated
We can continue and say that 4 is 2 × 2
But as you see it's a full box, so
We will stop at him
This second phrase can be written -6 ×
Square root of 16 × square root of 2
These are here - I want to be clear - are the same
Square root of 16 × 2
They can be separated as such
Square root of 16 × 2 = square root of 16 ×
Square root of 2
We have seen that this is one of the characteristics of the foundations
Now, what is the simplification of this phrase?
This is 3
These 2
If we have 3 × 2 × square root for 2
Ie 6 x square root of 2
And here we start by saying - well, how much
Result of this phrase?
Positive 4
If 6 × 4 = 24, × square root of 2
We have not finished yet
If I had 6 elements I wanted to subtract them
24, how much do I have left?
I have 6 square roots for 2 and I want to subtract them
24 squared root for 2, well, this
Equals 6 - 24 = -18 square root of 2
I hope this did not confuse you
And remember, if we have 6x - 24x, it will be output
-18x
Now, we have a square root of 2 instead of x
6 elements - 24 items equals
-18 element
Let's solve one another
Suppose I have a square root of 180 + 6 ×
Square root of 405
This issue can be simplified
Its roots, as we did before
But you did not get enough exercise to do this
Let us then find factors
this is
If 180 is 2 × 90, 90 is 2 × 45
And 45 = 5 × 9
We can analyze the 9 to become 3 × 3 so realize it
A whole square, but we can leave it that way
If the first phrase can be written like this:
Square root of 2 × 2 × square root of 5 ×
Square root of 9
I will place the square root for 9 out
If the square root of 2 × 2 × square root of 5
× Square root of 9
Now, how much is this second phrase?
To analyze them to their causes
5 × - I think 81
But even proved it, 405, 4 do not divide by 5
Let 's move to 40
40 5 5 = 8
8 x 5 = 40
We ask
We get 0
Download 5
5 5 5 = 1
True, 81
81 is 9 × 9
We can analyze more if we want to extract
The fourth root of this amount, but here we want
Sqrt
We have 9 and 9, and we do not need to extract more factors
If this second phrase is 6 ×
Square root of 9 × 9 × square root of 5
How much output?
This is 3
These 2
This square root of 4
If 3 x 2 is equal to 6
If we have 6 square roots for 5
+ - How much is this product?
Square root of 9 × 9 = square root of 81
It is of course 9
6 × 9 = 54, if +54 square root of 5
And then, what do we have left?
We have 6 + 54
And equal to 60
So
Let's solve another issue and we will have some
Shortcuts here
Now we will deal with the variables
I want it so I'll show you that
Variables do not change anything
Suppose we have a square root
For 48a
I want to add to it the square root of 27a
Again, let's analyze 48 factors
And we leave a alone
If 48 are 2 x 24, 24 is 2 x 12
Sorry, 2 × 12, and 12 = 3 × 4
If we can write this first phrase
Square root of 2 × 2 × square root of 4 ×
Square root of 3
Maybe you will do this in a faster way
You analyze it to 3 and 16 and notice it quickly
To be 16 is a square full
But I did it this way until I told you
We will get the same output at the end
Of course, not only the square root of 3, but also
We have an extra square root for 3
I will put the a here
I can put them in a separate root, but both
They are not full boxes, so I'll leave them under
Root code
Now the 27 is 3 × 9
9 is a full box, we can stop here
This is the second phrase, and we can rewrite it to become the square root
For 9 × square root for 3a
They can both see - I jump on
A middle step
The middle step, I can write these
The first expression is as: square root for 9 × 3a and then
Go to this step
But I think you've got enough practice to realize that
(9 × 3a) ^ 1/2 or that
We take the square root, where all this is equal
Square root for 9 × square root of 3a
This is the step I jumped from
But I hope, this did not confuse you much
If this phrase becomes 2
This term will become 2
If it becomes our 4 × square root for 3a
And then divide these on these, these 3
We have + 3x square root for 3a
4 + 3 =
Anyway, I hope this has helped you